et on dirait que dans cette édition ryan
shelby président de l'association pour
la promotion de la coopération et de
l'amitié entre la france et la tunisie
bonsoir hayat chaibi merci d'être avec
nous sur arte france ce soir bonsoir
vous êtes en france mais quand vous
voyez ce reportage de ben hassen chébili
est désert nasri qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque de la colère et de la tristesse
de la colère parce que on voit bien que
la situation est incontrôlable
il n'est pas en mesure d'être maîtrisés
malheureusement et de la tristesse parce
que c'est il n'y a pas de mots pour
décrire ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
tunisie ou en coûte près de 100 morts
par jour je dis bien 100 morts par jour
dans un pays qui compte 11 millions
d'habitants c'est à dire l'équivalent
population de la région ile-de-france
donc de la colère et de la tristesse
mais je veux croire qu'il reste encore
quelque chose de possible et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la mobilisation de
toutes et tous de la diaspora de la
communauté internationale est plus que
nécessaire
et justement la tunisie qui appelle à
l'aide sa diaspora l'autre côté de la
méditerranée concrètement comment les
tunisiens de france peuvent-ils aider
tunis sachant que la france a placé hier
à la tunisie sur un sa liste au rouge
des pays à risque whisky ce qui en soi
est logique un compte tenu de la
situation sanitaire
mais moi je voudrais surtout parler des
actions qui sont mises en place
aujourd'hui par la diaspora cette
richesse tunisienne de l'étranger comme
j'aime à les appeler qui se mobilisent
partout sur le territoire français du
nord au sud de l'est à l'ouest pour
aider les tunisiennes et les tunisiens
avec le concours des autorités
tunisiennes puisque sur instruction du
président de la république à sayyed
les autorités tunisiennes ont été mis à
profit l'ambassade de la république
tunisienne les différents consulats pour
récolter le matériel médical et
l'acheminer dans les plus brefs délais
en tunisie à travers la direction
la direction d âme comment dirais-je de
la santé militaire pardon qui acheminera
directement le matériel en tunisie et
donc pour le coup avec notre association
par exemple nous organisons dès samedi
une collecte d'équipements médicaux à
noisy-le-grand à la salle jean moulin
à livry gargan et puis comment dirais-je
à epinay sur seine à la maison des
associations et pour récolter ce
matériel médical et l'acheminer dans les
plus brefs délais en tunisie pour
classer le tissu associatif qui
travaillent mais on sait qu'il ya aussi
un manque de vaccins la france fournir
dans les semaines à venir plus d'un
million de doses le maroc également
annoncé l'envoi d'une aide médicale
d'urgence la solidarité c'est ce qui
peut donner un peu de répit à la tunisie
c'est un bol d'oxygène
on l'a bien vu et vous la voulez bien
vous venez de l'évoquer la tunisie va
recevoir une aide importante de la
france plus d'un million de vaccins
comme celle de l'arabie saoudite qui va
envoyer un million de vaccins l'algérie
également envoyé du matériel médical et
d'oxygène le maroc la mauritanie la
turquie l'egypte la mode la colle à la
communauté internationale se mobilise
donc forcément ça va donner un bol
d'oxygène à la tunisie est elle en a
bien besoin et on va continuer à se
battre à ses côtés pour essayer en tout
cas de de freiner l'épidémie
vous avez évoqué ce mot je voulais vous
venir dessus la communauté
internationale qui se mobilisent
vous avez parlé du tissu associatif mais
quel rôle concret de la communauté
internationale est ce qu'elle peut aller
suffisamment loin quand on voit tout ce
qui se passe déjà dans les problèmes
inhérents dans les pays dits avancés est
ce que les pays riches on l'a vu avec le
système kovacs qui est qui est difficile
à mettre en place un peu partout est ce
que est ce que les pays riches
ce souci véritablement des pays les plus
en difficulté comme la tunisie écoutez
en tout cas la france s'agissant de la
france elle elle prend sa part de
responsabilité mais on peut toujours
faire plus l'union européenne par
exemple peut faire plus peut mobiliser
un certain nombre de pays de l'union
européenne pour envoyer du matériel
médical et des vaccins bien évidemment
la tunisie est le pays le plus frappé
par la crise sanitaire le plus frappé
d'afrique mais également du monde arabe
en il faut faire plus et naturellement
que dans le cas du dispositif kovacs il
ya une nécessité d'accroître l'aide à la
tunisie parce qu'on le voit bien
la tunisie est en train comment
dirais-je de sombrer dans cette crise
sanitaire
il faut également être à ses côtés et
donc dans cette danse est dans cet
épisode que nous sommes en train de
vivre
l'union européenne partenaire important
de la tunisie doit prendre toute sa
place et toutes ses responsabilités aux
côtés de la france pour aider la tunisie
et faire en sorte qu'elles sortent au
moins en tout cas par le haut si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi de cette crise merci
riad à la cheville et d'avoir répondu à
une question je rappelle que vous êtes
le présidentialisation pour la promotion
de la coopération et de l'amitié entre
la france et la tunisie